yes so my name is V tulas I'm a CEO
co-founder of a bounds like where we um
continue developing metaflow MLA AI
infrastructure in general I used to lead
ml infrastructure at Netflix before and
that's of course like where we studied
metaflow and so we have been doing this
thing for for now a good number of
years um actually I wanted to start with
um with kind of a bit of a perspective
here so like starting with this question
that like how does a techsavvy company
overall like to comput how have they
done compute over time and of course I
mean like starting with the very obvious
I mean it's always fun to take a bit
longer term point of view is that like
if you go to the very beginning of
computing I mean way before python um
like of course you did Punch Cards not
many many options there um interestingly
enough um maybe in in in 70s 80s you
started having these mini computers like
which was this idea that instead of
having a room full of computers so at
least you could have something that
maybe fits in a in a in a single office
and then you can do your data process
processing there in that environment and
um now an interesting thing is that um
then maybe at some point in in the 80s
and the 2000s if you were a um some ofat
of a serious Enterprise and you wanted
to do data processing there were good
number of providers like teradata and
Oracle and others that sold you this
database Appliance is actually like a
rack full of computers that were fully
integrated for for data processing and
compute and so forth and uh I remember
like when I when I when I used to work a
long time ago at Nokia they had a big
trata Warehouse like where you could
like run your compute workloads and of
course it was a very special precious uh
enterprise Enterprise environment where
you could do these things and it was on
the one hand of course like as as you
would expect from Enterprise Hardware it
was very reliable and and like very
tightly created but the big downside was
that also it was extremely limiting and
didn't of course like leave many options
for any kind of experimentation or new
kind of workloads or anything of that
sort
so now the the kind really the
interesting thing that happened then um
like in the early 2000s some of you may
remember that um uh Google published a
paper about this Paradigm called map
reduce uh I think it was 2004 and then
it to couple of years I think around
like 2006 2007 um Hadoop um the kind of
the most popular open source um map
reduced framework was released and then
I I think like as an industry and I I'm
sure that like many of you remember as
well we spent maybe at least 10 years
like kind of deploying increasingly
large Hadoop deployments and then like
using the map reduce Paradigm and I
think like one reason why it was so
exciting for for many people at the time
is that like if you contrast that to to
what existed before with these database
appliances now suddenly we were in this
environment where we could well first I
mean handle much more uh flexible
workloads and also there was this
amazing idea that we could use commodity
Hardware instead of in of like going to
one of these expensive Enterprise
vendors we could just get off the shell
of computers rack and stack them in
these clusters and like there was also
this promise coming from Google of of
having this infinitely scalable
horizontal compute that like as our data
sets grow we can do more and more like
just by adding more machines and then
also like we had these really Nifty
compute paradigms like like map Ru that
like supposedly like made certain things
things easier so I think that like
although now of course many of us may
kind of like remember having like not
not so great memories how hard it was to
actually do many of the things that are
quite standard these days the big
benefit was that like it definitely was
a jump forward like from like things
used to be in the past now of course the
kind of the other other big development
that has been happening and of course
there's a certain overlap here as well
of course like people have been doing
like Cloud way before
2017 uh but like really if you think
about like that your average stav
company I mean it took a good number of
years like before Cloud really became
mainstream but then there was this idea
that okay I mean now we can actually
start scaling in the cloud instead of
like building these ever increasing data
centers and like building our own racks
of
machines and now I guess like what's
what's really interesting here and kind
of like really the motivation for this
talk I mean this is not just a doing a a
kind of historical perspective on like
what has been happening but I mean also
like equally much about what's going to
happen in the future it's it's really
like interesting to see that there there
is actually like very much a shift
happening now between that like early
days of the cloud and of course Amazon
and like E2 that was pretty much the OG
the first first Cloud that was available
and if you look at the landscape today
it is much more diverse I mean of course
obviously like we have three major Cloud
providers we have AWS we have Azure we
have gcp but in addition we have many
specialized providers like let's say
like un need gpus you can go to cor
weave you can go to lampol Labs we have
even specialized Hardware of course like
uh coming from Nvidia AMD sess and so
forth so it's it's a much more diverse
landscape than ever before
and now one one thing that's really um
useful to to kind of also consider like
in this perspective is overall like the
amount of compute that like we as a
humankind we are performing and uh of
course like in in the very early days I
mean only very few companies even could
afford the computer so honestly they
kind of the amount of compute performed
by the humankind was so small that it's
it's kind of not even visible here and
and like even in the in the early days
still I mean like in in the grand scheme
of things like there wasn't much
anything there I think that like really
really like things started taking off uh
like with the with the kind of this like
a big data boom um like kind of like
since the since the early 2000s and of
course the cloud cloud is um now oh
sorry happening as
well but like really the kind of the
major like and this is of course like a
big prediction like what's going to
happen in the future is that uh there
are like a certain things that are
really really like driving the compute
and I think like there's a case to be
made that like we are still in the very
very early days of the compute boom and
now now it feels that of course like oh
my gosh we are doing so much more than
before but as as you know how things go
with the exponential curves I mean it is
definitely the case that we are doing
twice the amount what we were doing like
just a couple of years back but I mean
like we are still we will be doing twice
more and twice more and so forth for for
for years to come and uh now like when
when you actually like I think about
that like what are we actually doing and
like what do these Tav companies
actually compute one thing that's uh
absolutely like worth noting is that for
the longest time like probably since the
the late 70s or so pretty much most
compute workloads uh of course like
putting putting some like a super
Computing work lows aside I mean but the
most normal mainstream companies like
what they have been doing is pretty much
like a run things but I call like sequel
is meaning that of course let's say like
during the the Hado boom I mean there
was the whole no SQL movement I mean it
wasn't exactly SQL but I mean it's all
this like a data processing operations
selecting projecting um like mashing
data in in in all kind of ways which
like again like we are kind of back to
the starting point again like very
happily using SQL with data bricks and
and Snowflake and and whatnot so that
has been kind of the the base load like
for the longest time and now of course
like this is this is like probably not
not surprising that like the really the
new thing and I think that this is like
really quite exciting that for the first
time in in many decades there's actually
something different than like running
this like a data processing in different
forms maybe I mean even like a map
reduce was just like a Different Twist
on on on like kind of doing something
that's equal is but now like with the
llms and and so forth like we have a
whole new workload that is driving
massive amount massive increase in the
amount of compute that we want to
perform and it it looks very different
than what we have been doing in the
past so now just like a quickly
motivating like because I think it's
also like this helps to understand some
of the technological shifts that are
happening so the first question is that
like why did we actually like move like
from this um horizontal scaling map
reduce how do in this like scaling in
the cloud um some of you may have seen
this paper like really good paper you
should look it up um you can Google for
the name scalability but what at cost
which um like really like is very like a
concise point that they are making is
that like although you can have these
horizontally scalable systems like map
reduce often times the performance can
be actually worse than what we have in
in corresponding single node systems
just because of the networking overhead
and the the unoptimized implementations
and so forth and just to give you an
anecdote um like really a concrete
example of this is that for instance
like when I when I used to work at
Netflix in the early days like if this
was already many years ago Netflix had
their own distributed implementations of
number of machine learning algorithms
running on spark and and they were proud
of the fact that they were able to run
larger scale machine learning models
than than pretty much anyone else like
thanks to these custom implementations
and then um in in 2015 um tensor flow
was released and of course in in some
ways tensor flow is a python framework
but of course like the whole like a key
to tensorflow is that it actually is um
very high performance implementation
utilizing gpus and so for under under
the hood and now at some point they
started comparing this distributed spark
um implementations to this single node
python process that is of course now
leveraging gpus and so forth under the
hood and this single node implementation
in many case was able to beat the
performance of the distributed system
exactly kind of going to the to the
point of this this AR
and and of course this was like really
quite surprising since for the longest
time like when we were in that
horizontal scalability world I mean the
idea was that that python is just way
too slow and like in order to really do
things at Large Scale in order to handle
big data you need you need this like a
hyper a little bit more high performance
languages like Java and like you need to
distribute the workload and so forth but
I mean that landscape started
shifting and also like with the the
horizontal scalability the idea was
always that it's such a beautiful idea
that you can keep adding more machines
in your cluster and and things just
become magically uh kind of faster and
like more scalable and and although this
idea of vertical scalability had been
around forever especially with those
appliances there was the feeling that oh
but anyways I mean you will hit the
limits of vertical scal scalability so
fast and it's kind of expensive to buy
bigger Oracle boxes and that's why
horizontal scalability initially was so
appealing but now the thing with the
cloud and what this chart shows um is
this actually goes back to 2006 and like
kind of continues until 2019 so this is
I had I I should update this chart now
with the latest developments here as
well but what it shows you is that it
shows you that what's the kind of the
available uh memory in the largest
available general purpose easy2 instance
in the AWS cloud and actually like when
when AWS started they only had these M1
small instances with one gigabyte the
largest instance you could get in ec2 in
the early days was only having one
gigabyte of memory and then like a
couple of years after they they released
the machine with 15 gigabytes of memory
so of course a massive increase there
and again like a few years after that
they released this machine like with 68
gigabytes of memory and now like this
thing kept going so that um over the
next uh how how much is that like over
the next 13 years the kind of the
largest machine had 768 times more
memory than like when they started so
pretty much exponential growth there
which meant that like anybody could go
in like and click a button like in AWS
and get the machine with absolutely
crazy amount of memory and this was back
in 2019 and even today like kind of
having a box with 700 gigabytes of RAM
is is is a pretty is capable of handing
like pretty decent size
data now I mean just to illustrate the
point um like this is an example that I
have have given in the past as well is
that if you consider this data frame uh
like a npy matrix where you have on the
on the roast you have let's say like
kind of a members of of Netflix and and
then like you have a bunch of features
bunch of information for for every
member of the company and you you encode
this as btes what's really interesting
to consider is that like that's the
amount of data required to to keep all
Netflix members in memory is like shown
here as this red area and of course like
Netflix in the early days was growing
really rapidly like let's say starting
from 2008 uh like a growing growing
growing and growing but like let's say
like if in this data frame you used one
bite uh uh like for every column and you
had thousand columns what it means is
that like kind of you could have get all
the information about all the Netflix
members conveniently in in a single nony
Matrix uh like all the time I mean just
because of the fact that like the the
kind of the compute capacity was growing
so much faster than like this like a
fast growing service at the time and now
of course you could say that well I mean
maybe one kilobyte is it's not enough
but I mean let's let's kind of consider
the case where you have three kilobytes
per member and even in this case I mean
despite like some kind of uh periods of
In Time time like most of the time like
you were able to even keep this larger
data frame in in memory like on these
instances and of course this development
I mean honestly like kind of a it's even
easier today unfortunately in a sense
that like Netflix hasn't kept go growing
quite as exponentially but the instances
keep getting bigger and bigger and of
course like efficient in in all possible
ways and what this says is that like one
shouldn't underestimate like the amount
of kind of the the capacity and the
resource increases that have happened
like even like within a single BLX in
the cloud and this doesn't even take
into account the gpus which totally
again changed the
picture now the um the other interesting
kind of thing to consider here is that
like okay so now we used to have this
like a scale in the cloud for the for
the many many years and we still do but
now like I I would argue that like we
are even like moving to the next level
which is that the landscape of just like
running everything on AWS like what we
used to do with the Netflix I mean that
is even like getting much more diverse
and
heterogeneous and there a couple of
reasons like why why this is happening
well I mean one one overall like trend
is that like when companies were barely
moving to the cloud uh everybody did the
simplest possible thing I mean like this
was a new thing I mean that the system
was very immature didn't afford like
many options anyway but overall like
kind of a more and more Cloud users are
getting increasingly sophisticated about
their usage and like with that they're
also like becoming very sophisticated
about how they think about the cost of
using this things so the the original
idea was that well instead of having
your big own data centers and like your
own um own people maintaining these
clusters it can be more cost efficient
just to move everything to the cloud and
in many cases that is that is very true
but then also there are different ways
of using the cloud and like the simplest
possible way of using the cloud is
absolutely like not the not the most
coste efficient and now increasingly
like being people are getting getting
like aware of this and like this is
funny enough a picture like from the
from the AWS re invent talk uh keynote
that just happened was last week or the
two weeks before H where now AWS itself
is very much like due to the market
Market pressures like kind of um um
really like putting forward this idea of
like doing things in a very sustainable
and cost aware manner now the the other
reason like why why things are getting
more heterogeneous is obviously the fact
that there's simply more competition and
like it used to be that AWS was way
ahead of everybody else arguably maybe
it still is but Azure gcp many others I
mean they are absolutely becoming viable
options so it's it's of course like good
for the users because there's more
competition more options uh like more
opportunities to also kind of leverage
like the different different options
however you want now also like a third
development that has made this whole
like a hybrid setup and more diverse
setup more feasible is actually
kubernetes so it used to be so that if
you built your systems using AWS native
apis were of course absolutely locked in
on AWS it was impossible to move a
system build specifically for a AWS to
Azure or gcp but now if you build your
system natively for kubernetes you run
it in eks you run it on AKs on asure or
like you run it on the whatever like a
Google compute engine uh on on the
Google side so actually like you can
actually start moving between different
systems you can actually start building
this more like hybrid deployments of
course including on Prem more
easily now another thing and of course
like very relevant for the for everybody
here at the pi data conference is that
um the the pi data ecosystem by itself
has been getting like very very like
mature like which is super super
exciting so it used to be so that we
have we had numpy of course we have had
nump for for I think a couple of decades
now um but um and also like we have had
pandas but I mean of course especially
with pandas the performance wasn't
always there but now over the past I
don't know like a four four years or so
like we have started getting a much more
mature ecosystem of very high
performance libraries of course the
apach providing like many lowlevel
capabilities like alternative data
frames like polers what super exciting
that like we can even do SQL now thanks
to things like Duck DP and we can build
Enterprise crate data leges using using
things like Iceberg and then mix and
match these different tools which means
that like we have way more options for
choosing the best tool for the job so in
contrast to the days when like let's say
the only only option was to run
everything on Hadoop suddenly like if
let's say your data fits on in in memory
like you can use duck DP and like maybe
you don't need anything distributed I
mean it's going to be beautifully fast
faster than anything else that you can
do and now of course like absolutely
like kind of the the the crazy
development that has happened this year
um is is this massive explosion uh with
with the AI and llms and this is a this
is like a fun fun projection like about
the cost of of training the largest
scale AI models and there are
projections that training these AI
models like will require so much compute
that it way surpasses the the projected
US GDP well I don't think that like we
ever like quite get to that point but it
is absolutely obvious that this is the
one thing that will be driving the
demands for a compute for the for the
coming years and of course especially as
of today many of you have felt this like
situation of being GPU poor not being
able to even access like the the Nvidia
Hardware that has been pretty much
required to kind of a join join this
bandwagon this year but um of course
like in the in the coming years there
there will be many other Alternatives
like all the clouds are developing their
own Hardware AMD is is developing their
own Hardware Nvidia is of course like a
very much like a trying to maintain
their lead and so forth so it's going to
be very very exciting for the for the
coming
years
now overall like where this all takes us
like kind of looking at these trend
lines is that it it feels that it's
absolutely the golden age of python
compute so if you think about like where
we came from like in this uh scalable uh
horizontally scalable world like we had
things like Hado and and Spark and of
course dask was an amazing answer in the
python land if you didn't want to use
these these mechanisms but um but now uh
when when we when we started moving in
the cloud I mean like at least like we
we got a few more options many many of
us like use things like Amazon EMR which
was basically kind of a nicer version of
Hado now like running in the cloud and I
just wanted to give a Kos to this
service called py Cloud that made it
easy to run python in the cloud already
many many years ago I think that like
that company was way ahead it ahead of
its time but there were these attempts
to start providing better python
alternatives for for many of us in in
this new
world and now of course like what has
been Trail placing Trail placing this
this new world uh of of being able to do
really demanding compute with python are
all these uh Frameworks uh for for for
like a running um like different machine
learning models like tension flow and a
p torch and so forth and what's
remarkable about them is that there's an
absolute crazy amount of um brain power
that goes into optimizing these
Frameworks and making sure that they
they leverage the hardware resources
optimally and and that allows like all
of us to do amazingly demanding compute
in Python that absolutely like wasn't
possible I mean it's kind of surus is
what was even possible using C and C++ a
few years
ago and now like getting to the the main
main kind of like a point of this talk
is that in this world and especially
like for for all of us using python it's
kind of interesting that um like what
what are the Frameworks we want to use
to to kind of U like really provide the
compute substrate in in this world and
uh when we started working on metaflow
2017 it definitely was in this like a
scale in the cloud world like we were at
Netflix Netflix is a big s user we
wanted to make it very easy to Leverage
The Cloud resources in the cloud uh so
that like any data scientist could say
that here's my python function I I need
like a big machine to handle my pandas
data frame or like now I need to train
my model like py model and I need H gpus
for that and that's something that like
we have provided since the very early
days but now of course like in this new
world that is quickly emerging in this
like a mixing and matching there are
like even more capabilities that
metaflow is providing and I will talk
more about that
and for those of you who maybe not don't
know metaflow um from the past I
actually like won't be spending any time
going into details because Hugo will be
going right after me in a few minutes
and and like he will go into into
details about metaflow but uh saish to
say that the whole point of metaflow is
to think about the full stack of machine
learning infrastructure that you need to
build complete ML and AI systems
starting all the way from data and
compute orchestration all these like
very basic questions that are very
foundational and also like thinking
about this more um like a human
organizational concerns that how do you
keep track of all the work and how do
you deploy these systems as a part of a
larger larger kind of like a business
environment and of course at the very
top of the stack there's the question
that like how do you do modeling um and
of course the idea is that metaflow
doesn't provide an alternative and like
absolutely like it would be crazy to try
to do so to all the modeling Frameworks
that are out there but it really focuses
like you see from these triangles that
I'm providing this foundational
infrastructure like especially focusing
these questions of compute data uh
orchestration and versioning so that
like when you are like one of the one of
the data developers data scientist ml
Engineers sitting at the top of the
stack you can really focus on leveraging
these Frameworks and you can get the
computer sources when you
need and again I I I don't want to spend
too much time on on like going into
details about metaflow again more about
that in a few minutes but the basic idea
is that it's a it's a very simple uh
python framework like the whole point is
to focus on the developer experience
that allows you to create uh endtoend
workflows purely python no need to write
any EML but let's say now when you need
compute resources you can simply say for
instance at kubernetes memory 64,000 I
need 64 gigabytes of RAM to execute this
python function and then like when
metaflow has been configured to work in
your environment that just like that
that function execution you don't have
to worry about it all the code gets
packaged automatically even dependencies
are handled as a part of this execution
you can say that I want this version of
psychic learn or whatever it might be or
like then you can also make this so that
this this workflow works as as a lar as
a part of a larger larger like like
workflow and as as a part of a larger
system now like going to the kind of
main main theme of this presentation and
and like where the well the world is
really going is that there isn't one
size fits all solution so there isn't
like a one universal Paradigm like what
we try to do with map reduce where you
can say that oh I mean just like follow
this Paradigm and suddenly everything
will get everything will get scalable
and everything will get high performance
I mean honestly that doesn't happen like
the world where we are entering um
quickly is is the one where there are
very many heterogeneous workloads
sometimes you need gpus sometimes you
need horizontal scalability sometimes
you need a big box for for like to
handle like all your Enterprise data in
a duck DP instance and you need to be
able to to choose the kind of the right
Paradigm of of of compute very flexibly
and I will just like a go through the
kind of a few like a basic models what
we support and I I think it's always
worth mentioning that the starting point
the Baseline should always be that like
you don't have to worry about
scalability and performance and I think
that this is the big mistake that that
many of these like previous attempts
including map reduce have made that
there's the idea that well you kind of
have to pay the the scalability tax and
performance tax no matter what you do
and especially like for all of us coming
from the python background like who are
like very used to kind of keeping simple
things simple it it kind of feels that
like why why does it have to be so that
like even the simplest possible things
have to be complicated and of course
that that shouldn't be the case but
let's say if you have the the most
simplest um uh like use case whatever it
might be maybe you have a small amount
of data it's not business critical I
Trans on my laptop I want to keep life
simple what you can do is that you don't
have to worry about anything it's just
like a write python code as you always
do and then it just runs and actually
you can go surprisingly far with that um
thanks to the amount like amount of
power that you just have on your laptop
or Cloud workstation or whatever it is
might be so also means that you can
develop locally quickly because you
don't have to worry about things that
are maybe in the
future now the the most obvious thing
like when when you want to start scaling
up should be always this idea that well
I mean let's just like get more
resources for the function so let's say
I have a big pandas data frame um it out
of it goes out of memory in my notebook
because maybe it needs 64 gigabytes
maybe 128 gigabytes so instead of
changing anything on my code I mean why
don't we just get the box in the cloud
that has efficient resources to handle
that data frame so for instance in this
case I say that okay in order to execute
this function I need 8 gabt of RAM and
then I can handle Panda data frame like
as long as it stays below 8 gigabytes
and if I need more I I just keep
increasing that number and I get bigger
boxes and as I showed you before in that
graph I mean it's just amazing how far
you can go with this approach and thanks
to the fact that this function only
executes I mean or the instances are
only needed for the duration of this
function it can be very cost efficient I
as well because you not SP you're not
like launching a big cluster of these
boxes that are just idling there but
like we like you know AWS charges by
second so you say that okay now we need
128 gigabytes for 15 seconds like we use
that of course like it might be that we
have to launch the box there but it goes
down and like you actually like end up
paying pennies for
that now what what makes this vertical
scalability approach even more exciting
is the fact that now you can leverage
these Hardware accelerators like gpus
and I can say that well actually like
give me the box with the a100 and with a
GPU so that I can fine tune my large
language model I can fine tune the Llama
too and now again like if you operate in
an environment where you have these
resources available um that's all you
have to do and now you can use pytorch
you can use hugging phase like off you
go and like you just say that okay I
mean these are the resources I
need now another uh form of of of
compute is this idea of a task
parallelism where we basically take the
same data data but we perform two
different operations for the data and
like use case of this might be that
let's say you want to compare two
different models um like where you have
the same data set and like maybe you
take a llama 2 as a foundation model
versus like whatever gptj or or
something like that or like maybe you
have um just like a two different like
algorithms that you want to run for your
data set and then you just say that okay
I want to do the self I I want to do the
step a and the step B and maybe they
even have different resource
requirements and like metaflow takes
care of like running those things in
parallel and sorry sorry to interrupt
Vil I'm sorry but we've reached our time
and if people would like to switch over
to the tutorial I'm I'm so sorry yeah I
know so yeah I know I mean like yeah
definitely you should H talk so yeah I
just wrap up really quickly so then this
is the the horizontal scalability idea
you can do things in parallel or like
just as a quick note um we also have
this new feature that if you want to do
distributed Compu in a sense that like
you want to have many boxes
communicating that is actually a new
feature that was just released about a
month ago you should just check it out
so this was pretty much all I wanted to
say here in this presentation you should
definitely join Hugo stop next what I
also worth mentioning Works in all
clouds also your on on Prem instances
and now the best way to get started is
actually to join Hugo's uh talk that is
starting right now and also like join
the metaflow community so we can answer
any questions there as well thank you